Watchmen was a big shift because that
was I felt way out of my league on that
one um I really struggled because it was
such a big film and I really felt like I
had no idea what I was doing I had no
training and I was working with these
fabulous theater actors who had all the
training in the world I definitely
didn't feel worthy of being there I felt
like I had tricked them into casting me
you know there was a lot of stuff going
that I was going through so it was
definitely a shift and I just said all
right
I can't just follow now anymore I have
to start making decisions of what it is
that I want to learn where it is what
direction I want to go and what do i
what do I like creatively what do I find
fun what away you know I want to put my
best foot forward I don't want to feel
like I'm in that position where I feel
like I'm the weakest link in a
production you know so yeah that
probably was a little bit of a turning
point were you feeling that way
throughout the entirety of making
Watchmen or was there a point during the
production where you kind of started to
gain some confidence and feel like you
were worthy to be among that group it
was an ebb and flow from day to day some
days I felt better than others but um
yeah for the most part I just because
everyone I was working with was just so
darn good that I died I really I guess I
noticed the difference of I realized
that I didn't know how to prepare for a
role and they did and that was really
getting to me and not and not it wasn't
like it was more just I was disappointed
in myself that I hadn't taken more time
before going into this but I realized
the reason I didn't was because I didn't
know the direction I was going in I
wasn't leading my own way you know what
I mean so nowadays I'll take roles and
I'll make sure that it's something that
I can develop and work with and that I
find interesting and and that I come in
prepared how do you make sure you look
back on it in a positive way in order to
get past that and then build on a
stronger path for yourself it's a good
question I think that
it's important to remember that this
this type of work is creative and
creativity is a constant growth there is
no end and that was just part of the
journey and it had to happen in order it
was it's a catalyst everything becomes
sort of a catalyst for something out so
you know I look back on it now I loved
the experience as far as the people I
got to work with and and to have been a
part of that beautiful production and
I'm thankful that it woke me up a little
bit to you know the importance of
preparation and and just so that I
couldn't grow from that experience I
think any growth then it's it's been
worth it but and also I've I say this to
my friends sometimes it's just so
interesting because a lot of people at
their jobs they sit find you can't see
them you know they're not in front of a
camera we're doing our jobs we're still
figuring out our jobs and then it's
printed and people are watching it and
it's never a finished product you know
so it's always a work in process and we
watch actors from the beginning of their
careers
Schwartz the end of their career is Nico
Wow they've grown so much so for me to
watch other people as well I've gone
yeah it's it's a process and that's okay
I've got to accept that you know some
some projects are gonna go better than
others and as long as you walk away from
it with some sort of growth in some sort
of learning then it was worth it you
know having had that experience on
Watchmen if another let's say you know
like a big brand superhero big budget
type thing comes your way has that
experience at all and I like I don't
even mean it in in like a negative way
towards Watchmen but just as far as your
tastes and roles though does that change
whether or not you would want to do
something like that again I would
absolutely do something like that again
I'm ready for it this time I would love
to do it actually you would feel like I
get a second chance at it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]